I think fundamentally looking at the
good work that's been done by the
council and in particularly the momentum
that's building across Europe now with
regard to fight with the home investment
it seems like a perfect opportunity to
really try and build on the efforts from
my predecessors and it was the natural
change in the guard within the Council
of recent times where the previous
president dr. acre came to the natural
conclusion of his term with the council
and I felt it was a great opportunity to
try and bring my experience to the
council and really try and further the
efforts that we've seen so far today
I think we're entering probably the most
exciting era that I've observed in
fibers a home connectivity across Europe
if we look at the activities that are
going on in countries like Spain and
countries like Luxembourg countries like
France where we're seeing unprecedented
levels of connectivity in precedent
levels of investment going on but in
those countries and a lot of that's also
government backed investment I think
we're seeing increasing awareness of the
positive impacts that extensive fiber
connectivity that can bring to countries
with regard to attracting foreign direct
investment and creating employment so
really for me it's probably the as I
mentioned earlier the most exciting time
I've seen within the space and I'm only
hoping that we'll continue to build on
that momentum and make it even more
attractive for others to make that
investment
I think for any operators who are
embarking on the journey of building out
fiber-to-the-home infrastructure
keeping in mind most operators in Europe
have near a hundred years experience in
managing copper infrastructures for many
of them as they embark on this new
journey their level of experience is
significantly less the fiber-to-the-home
Council and the community of members and
brings a wealth of information a wealth
of experience to all of the members
whether their observer members are full
members and it also creates an
environment where observer members can
gain access to some of the vendors
within the industry some of the
suppliers but in the industry some of
the contractors within the industry in a
non-commercial environment where people
are not trying to sell to them they're
sharing information on a neutral basis
which is extremely valuable for them and
finally I think ultimately if they take
on board the interaction they can have
with other observer members other
operators who've already embarked on
this farmer to the home mission and have
a lot of experience and knowledge that
they can share again in a very open and
friendly environment the benefits it's
very difficult to put a value on those
benefits from a their priceless
indeed it really was a fantastic success
one of the most successful conferences
we've had to date if I look at the
caliber of attendees it's significantly
increased over the last few years and in
particular last year what we saw was
really strong representation from the
operator community and this clearly
reflects the activity that we're seeing
out there in the industry where they're
out there actually building fiber
networks they're connecting people to
those networks and as a result they need
to get their employees exposed to the
broader fiber-to-the-home industry and
understand what the key innovations are
that are happening within the industry
who the key suppliers of equipment and
solutions are and really to learn the
lessons from the speakers at the
conference where they're sharing
valuable insights into their experience
in deployment
council it was a very easy decision for
us to make if we look at the sheer level
of investment that's going on in the
French market and fiber-to-the-home they
can be held up there amongst a small
handful of others within Europe as the
shining light for fiber-to-the-home
investment the sheer level of engagement
from the operator community the number
of suppliers engaged in these activities
we think for the broader
fiber-to-the-home community within
europe and operators seeking to get into
that space the lessons that we can learn
from those involved in the French and
initiatives are substantial and we feel
it would be remiss of us not to engage
at the French community and the the the
French location for the 2017 conference
we're looking forward to seeing you at
the 14th edition of the
fiber-to-the-home conference in
Marseille between the 14th and the 16th
of February 2017